we are seeing more of these abortion
denials for pregnant minors in the state
of Ohio this is the expected outcome of
what Republicans are doing no matter
what they say about this is regrettable
or this was not our intent this was the
predictable and expected outcome of the
states that are going hard against
abortion now that Roe v Wade has been
overturned by the Supreme Court we had a
story like this about six weeks ago and
now we have at least two more
cincinnati.com from the Ohio Capital
Journal reporting
two more pregnant minors who were raped
were denied Ohio abortions these are
disgusting and sickening circumstances
the article reads at least two more
minors made pregnant by sexual assault
were forced to leave Ohio to avoid
having their rapists babies according to
sworn affidavits filed by abortion
providers
the affidavits were filed in Cincinnati
as part of a lawsuit aimed at stopping
the enforcement of Ohio's strict new
abortion law originally paused for two
weeks the enforcement delay will be
extended until at least October 12th if
true and remember I don't sometimes say
affidavits aren't evidence affidavits
aren't evidence but they should be
looked at
um and evaluated if true the affidavits
show that a 10 year old from Columbus
Ohio was not the only child or teen rape
victim forced to leave the state they
also describe more than two dozen other
instances in which the abortion law put
women under extreme duress the
description includes those of three
women who threaten suicide and they
include two women with cancer who could
not terminate their pregnancies and also
couldn't get cancer treatment while they
were pregnant
that is a disgusting double-edged sword
and remember we talked about how this
develops
two things they can't get the abortion
because of Ohio abortion law and they
can't get the cancer treatment because
the cancer doctors are scared that the
cancer treatment could cause a
miscarriage and that they could be they
being the doctors could be charged for
facilitating an abortion
think of that it doesn't sound like what
the United States in 2022 is supposed to
be but unfortunately we are now getting
more and more of these stories
another three examples were of women
whose fetuses had severe abnormalities
or other conditions that made a
successful pregnancy impossible
even so they couldn't get abortions in
Ohio you know one of the things that's
often said
in opposition to abortion being legal in
most cases is these mothers shouldn't be
allowed to play God with people's lives
who are other people to make decisions
about other people's lives and you know
the truth is that decisions about other
people's lives are made all the time and
are often made at the end of life and at
the end of life when it is identified
that there is no brain activity and no
possibility for the recovery of brain
activity quote other people make
decisions about those lives and yet when
you have fetuses where there is no brain
activity they will not develop normally
these Republicans say no the mothers
shouldn't be allowed to make decisions
in those cases it's absolutely
horrifying so you've got situations
where you've got the potential for dead
moms and then orphans if even the mom
survives long enough to give birth if
even the fetus survives and um you've
got moms being forced to quote give
birth although to call it that is a bit
of an exaggeration or a misnomer
to dead fetuses and this is truly just
the tip of the iceberg many of these
stories will never even become known and
we have to ask who benefits who is it
good for
for women to be forced to stop Cancer
Treatments to travel out of state to get
an abortion and then to come back and
continue cancer treatment who benefits
from that who benefits from that and
remember they would talk about the
Obamacare death panels these are the
real death penals you know you had Sarah
Palin going around death panel this
death panel that didn't exist and by the
way by the way it is actually the denial
of Health Care Services altogether
that could be argued to be the real
death penalt This Is by Design now I
know Republicans will say that it is not
by Design we're not trying to create
these situations but it is predictable
it is predictable that this would happen
when you overturn Roe v Wade and then
States pass these horrifyingly strict
abortion laws what's the end game here
that's my question to you what is truly
the end game for Republicans is it just
to continue having situations like this
or is it that they believe these types
of situations will get people to rethink
their behavior in some way I don't I
don't actually know what the end game is
but what we do know is that banning
abortion doesn't eliminate abortion that
has been widely studied and we know that
so find me on Twitter at dpacman and
answer me the question what is the end
game here